avec les terroristes on ne discute pas
ces mots sont ceux d' emmanuel macron
dans un entretien accordé au magazine
jeune afrique en novembre dernier le
chef de l'état a réaffirmé la position
déjà très clair de paris sur la question
des négociations avec des terroristes
il faut s'inscrire dans la feuille de
route claire que sont les accords
d'alger
ceux ci prévoient au dialogue avec
différents groupes politiques et
autonomistes mais cela ne veut pas dire
qu'il faut dialoguer avec des groupes
terroristes qui continuent à tuer des
civils et des soldats y compris nos
soldats seulement voilà parmi les pays
aux côtés desquels la france combat
certains ont fait évoluer leur approche
de la question
ainsi le mali s'est plutôt montré
favorable à l'ouverture d'un dialogue
avec des groupes djihadistes la
négociation avec les groupes terroristes
ou le dialogue avec ces groupes pour
nous constitue la prise en charge d'une
volonté exprimée par les maliens
déjouant 2017
lors de la conférence d'entente
nationale et de tenir compte des
réalités nationales la france combattent
aux côtés de l'armée malienne notamment
dans le cadre de l'opération barkan pour
laquelle 5000 hommes sont engagés au
sahel une région qui mériterait selon
paris un positionnement plus subtil et
plus flexible que la doxa actuelle quant
à la question des négociations avec les
terroristes pas avec n'importe qui
cependant pas question d'inclure dans
les négociations des têtes d'affiché
d'acné d'al qaïda au maghreb islamique
ou du groupe etat islamique
mais par exemple certains membres du g
est 6ème le groupe de soutien à l'islam
et aux musulmans pourraient convenir
c'est en tout cas ce qu'a confié une
source au sein de la présidence
française à nos confrères de la fp
l'état majeur du gs im répond à la
hiérarchie central d'al qaïda est
totalement intégré dans son organigramme
personne n'a jamais réussi à négocier
avec al qaïda et ce n'est pas la france
qui va le faire mais certains éléments
du gscn montant d'un agenda beaucoup
plus nationale souvent opportunistes
parfois régional avec ses interlocuteurs
là il est possible d'avoir une autre
réponse il n'y a aucune raison pour la
france de faire obstruction à de telles
discussions
la france semble doucement entrouvrir la
porte des négociations en ce qui
concerne le mali
objectif une fois la capacité de
nuisance des leaders des groupes
terroristes neutraliser faire en sorte
que les différentes parties puissent
s'asseoir autour d'une table
une politique qui pourrait mener en
l'engagement de la france au sahel la
question du retrait de 600 hommes est
devenu envisageable selon la fpp
notamment au regard des résultats
obtenus sur le terrain et de la capacité
des sahéliens à je cite assumer le
service après vente
c'est à dire le travail de stabilisation
une fois les territoires conquis